Літо, море, переповнені пляжі.
Попри морські небезпеки й часті обстріли.
Побоюємося, звісно, але хочеться.
А якщо тривога, що будете робити?
Ну нічого, полежимо.
Якщо тривога… Ну як тривога, то до Бога!
Після заходу сонця літнє життя не припиняється.
Топ!
Я би залишився на все життя так відпочивати.
Це Одеса - чи не єдине місце в Україні,
де офіційно можна купатися в морі.
В Одеській ОВА запевняють, що морська вода
прийшла до норми після знищення Каховської ГЕС.
Нещодавно тут відкрили шість пляжів і не виключають,
що згодом їх може бути більше.
Саме ці пляжі, які вважаються безпечними,
обладнані антимінними сітками, обладнані буями.
З пляжу є декілька шляхів у разі евакуації.
Також ці пляжі обладнані гучномовцями -
при повітряній тривозі, щоб люди чули,
що повітряна тривога, вежами з рятувальниками.
Та нині люди купаються і на дозволених,
і на заборонених пляжах.
Військова адміністрація не може це зупинити.
Не зважаючи на те, що заборона ще була дійсна,
вони все одно ходять на пляж, вони купаються,
пляжі були під час спеки переповнені.
Замість того, щоб спостерігати за цим,
ОВА, головою ОВА Олегом Кіпером
після консультацій з військовими було прийнято рішення,
що треба убезпечити ділянки для оздоровлення людей.
Для декого офіційні дозволи влади не мають значення.
Людей не зупиняли ані забруднене море,
ані міни, що дрейфують.
Не переймаєтеся про безпеку? Міни запливають чи щось таке.
Я тут живу, які мені міни!
На Французькому [бульварі]. Я нічого не боюся.
В серпні набагато краще, десь у середині червня,
якраз два тижні після Каховської трагедії, гірше було.
Але було менше народу.
А ви купалися?
Звісно!
А як же? З моря виносило усіляке…
Та нічого там не виносило, трохи трісочок та і все.
Я взагалі родом з Бердянська, то в нас бувала холера,
в 70-ті роки, ми малими купалися, і, як бачите, живий і здоровий.
Ми з Миколаєва. Тому не хвилюйтеся, я знаю ваше питання про небезпеку.
Для нас Одеса - це дуже мирне місто.
Утім чимало хто прийшов на цей пляж саме тому,
що тут офіційно дозволили купатися.
За три роки минулі це вперше ми на морі.
Ми одесити, до речі.
Ну, як нам відпочивається? Довіряємо санепідемстанції,
яка каже, що море чисте, але далеко не занурюємося.
Перший раз за літо відвідав водойму.
Позитивні відчуття. Пляжі були закриті,
не було офіційного дозволу на купання.
І ризикувати не було сенсу.
Тому що якщо вони закриті, то на це має бути якась причина.
Цей "офіційний" пляж мав би бути обладнаний за всіма вимогами безпеки.
Утім сіток, які мали б стримувати міни, відпочивальники не помічають.
Я не знаю, як сітка. Є трос, який натягнутий там десь далі,
є буйки. Думаю, що сітки як такої немає.
Стрілки, що вказують напрямок до сховища,
дійсно ведуть до підземного укриття.
Утім зазвичай воно порожнє.
Орендар одного з пляжів, підприємець Юрій Дегас розповідає:
люди не зважають на небезпеки.
Перекритий прохід до пірса, але ви ж бачите,
людям все одно. Ми їм кажемо, але…
Народ настільки за два роки скучив за морем,
що їх, мені здається, нічого не зупинить.
За рік до повномасштабної війни Юрій обладнав платну
зону для відпочинку і безкоштовний пляж,
зокрема, й для людей з обмеженими можливостями.
Запевняє, що всі території для купання огороджені сітками,
дно щодня обстежують водолази,
а на постах чергують рятувальники.
Ми в липні практично тільки відкрилися.
Тому що з'явилася потреба і люди почали ходити.
Ми не можемо просто це кинути - ходіть, як хочете.
Ми вирішили це привести до ладу,
ще не було чіткого розуміння,
буде воно чи ні, але це ж наша репутація - порядок і краса.
Але люди пішли з моменту, як ОВА і місто дали добро,
що можна купатися. Це другі вихідні,
як дали роботу. Минулі - взагалі було божевілля.
Ось тут неможливо було лягти ніде,
пройти навіть неможливо було.
Утім нещодавно ось це відео розлетілося одеськими
Телеграм-каналами: заплутані антимінні сітки
не виконують свою функцію.
Юрій Дегас, на чиєму пляжі було зняте це відео, стверджує:
водолази розплутують сітки й кріплять на них вантажі.
Однак речниця оперативного командування "Південь"
Наталя Гуменюк раніше заявляла,
що сітки не гарантують того, що морська міна не здетонує.
Одеський еколог Владислав Балінський,
автор цих кадрів, теж не певен у цілковитій безпеці купання в морі.
Має й інші причини. Він регулярно стежить
за станом води в морі й життям морських мешканців.
Після нинішнього занурення має невтішні знахідки.
Ось бачите, я з собою взяв - це загиблі гідробіонти -
краби декількох видів, трьох видів, ось бичок.
Це вже через те, що температура води дуже висока -
зараз близько 30 градусів, погода безвітряна,
то є загроза масового замору.
Бо зараз у воду потрапила з підривом Каховської греблі
дуже багато біогенів - це продукти життєдіяльності
людини, змиви з полів, пестициди, добрива.
Всі вони є споживчим середовищем для живих істот,
для мікроорганізмів. Після такого підвищення
температури починається масове розмноження
і це може призводити до масових заморних процесів.
Ці кадри Владислав фільмував невдовзі після знищення
дамби Каховської ГЕС. Узбережжя, всіяне сміттям,
і осад з потрощеної деревини на дні.
Але наслідки відчутні й донині.
Хоча море біля Одеси вже солоне,
тут досі живуть качки, яких разом
з острівцями очерету принесло з Дніпра в море.
Владислав каже: в морі й нині рухаються об'єми води,
забруднені продуктами розкладання загиблих молюсків,
бактеріями, пестицидами.
Якщо ми кажемо про відкриття сезону,
то в серпні його зовсім недоречно відкривати,
бо якраз зараз є загроза велика.
Ще тиждень і почнуть дути постійні вітри
з боку гирла Дніпровсько-Бузького лиману,
а ці вітри посилять вплив забрудненої води
з Дніпровсько-Бузького лиману саме на наше узбережжя.
Війна не дає про себе забути й у місті.
В історичному центрі - зруйнований Спасо-Преображенський собор.
Неподалік морського узбережжя -
житловий комплекс, у який поцілив російський "Калібр".
А неподалік - музика, танці, атракціони.
Одеса відпочиває, поки є можливість.
Недорогі апартаменти ми знайшли.
Ціна не дуже велика, мабуть, через те, що зараз не сезон
через обстріли часті.
Дозволяємо собі самий мінімум,
але все одно хочеться покупатися в морі.
У мене регулярний платіж в приват-банку,
50 грн кожен день.
Я вважаю, я можу собі дозволити.
На ЗСУ?
Так, звісно.
Це курортний район Аркадія.
Ззовні видається, що тут усе, як раніше.
Та за словами місцевих, до повномасштабного вторгнення
в Аркадії було ще більш людно й гучно.
Здається мені, що це якось не дуже на часі,
але що зробиш, життя таке.
Людям також треба відключатися від війни,
якщо завжди думати про війну,
то можна і дахом поїхати, розумієте?
Тут зустрічаються і туристи, і вимушені переселенці.
Люди живуть і відпочивають,
нічого тут не зробиш, це життя.
Діти потребують цього, і нам потрібно це робити для них, так?
Ходити, трошки їх розвіювати, бо там важко і тут важко,
але діткам треба відпочивати.
А що тобі найбільше сподобалося тут в Аркадії?
Море. Море, так.
Люди трошки стрес знімають, можна так сказати. Трошки.
Ми за майже два роки війни стомилися це все переживати,
спати в підвалі, спати в коридорі.
Де ти спиш? В коридорі. Ось, в коридорі.
Невдовзі кафе й атракціони зачиняться.
До одинадцятої вечора курортна Аркадія порожніє,
адже опівночі - комендантська година - ще одне нагадування,
що в країні триває війна.